voici l'une des plus importantes
découvertes de l'histoire de la ville de
québec
les vestiges du premier rempart
construite au cours des années c'est 190
la structure a été retrouvé sur le site
d'une construction résidentielle elle
fait une vingtaine de mètres de long et
environ un mètre d'épaisseur
les archéologues du qualifie cette
découverte d'inestimables ya deux
critères font en sorte que québec a
nouvelle du patrimoine mondial c'est le
berceau de l'amérique française
et c'est une ville fortifiée donc
lorsqu'on vient de découvrir les
premières fortifications de québec
donc ça renforce le statut de ville du
patrimoine mondial le rempart ben ali
saad et de beaucourt qui porte le nom de
son concepteur est situé à quelques
centaines de mètres des fortifications
actuelle cette structure résistant aux
tirs de canon était essentiel si tu
possèdes québec tel accès jusqu'aux
grands lacs
donc c'est un enjeu important pour les
européens qui se battaient beaucoup
entre autres à l'époque pour l'amérique
du nord et également pour les iroquois
les amérindiens voulait chasser ces
français qui ne veut faire du commerce
donc il y avait une menace aussi jusqu'à
l'île dans l'ain donc avec deux menaces
il fallait se protéger quand ces deux
menaces heures le maire de québec a
visité les lieux en compagnie du premier
ministre
déjà on veut réserver une place de choix
à ces vestiges ses traits même à la
limite très émouvant on aime tellement à
cette villa de découvrir d'enfance qui
fait particulièrement de sa fondation
c'est ce que promet 10 16 92
j'en reviens peau et là il faut une
bonne idée pour utiliser ces va sûrement
parce qu'il faut que les gens puissent
voir le reconnaît ben sur baignés de
l'époque la récupération des
fortifications ou sera délicate
opération surtout avec l'arrivée du gel
ces grands défis le bois c'est préserver
dans le seul pendant 3 125 ans parce
qu'il était constamment gorgé d'eau ici
on le sort comme ça rapidement sans
traitement ça va être assez
catastrophique avec les celles du bois
vont s'effondrer quand ça va se produire
ça va être complètement irréversible les
spécialistes estiment que l'opération du
séchage du bois prendra environ deux ans
avant que le public puisse y avoir accès
ici nicolas venions radio canada québec